mona bonjour vous êtes dans le quartier
des halles de la capitale d'après ce
qu'on dit alors racontez moi quelle est
la situation les bars ont ouvert fermé
est ce qu'il ya du monde dans les
terrasses alors je suis actuellement à
san michele dans le restaurant à crème
de paris et vous l'avez dit il faut
désormais montrer patte blanche pour
pouvoir prendre un café déjeuner ou
encore ed din et je suis actuellement
avec stéphane qui est le patron de la
crème de paille qui situe à san michele
comme je le disais bonjour merci nous
accueillir alors on voit qu'il ya du
monde aujourd'hui
comment est ce que vous vous organiser
alors pour l'instant s'organise de
manière suivante les gens s'installent
et avant de prendre la commande
on leur demande gentiment de nous
montrer leur passe-temps fait on n'a pas
pris tout senti qu'au vu de contrôle on
l'a mais on préfère demander le passé
nous le font voir et à ce moment là on
les sert pour l'instant on n'a pas eu
énormément les clients saas et gérer
très facilement sur les trois
établissements que je gère ce matin j'ai
eu deux clients qui n'avaient pas les
passer donc on leur a demandé soit de
prendre à emporter soin d'aller boire
leur café ailleurs quoi aujourd'hui est
ce que vous craignez que ça ait des
conséquences justement sur le chiffre
d'affaires aujourd'hui qu'on voit on
voit qu'il ya quand même si peu de monde
et ce que d'habitude il ya plus de monde
non pour l'instant on peut pas dire que
les buts il ya plus de monde nous quand
même on en place notre dame on est on
est entre locaux vides et l' incendie
on n'est pas bien lotis en fait pour
l'instant on peut pas dire que ça que ce
soient réfractaires et que les gens
viennent moi
par rapport aux passes je pense que ce
sera plus le soir où effectivement
les gens sont pas encore tous dax inné
et et ça sera plus problématique pour
les pour la clientèle du soir à quillan
tel du matin c'est une clientèle qui
fréquente les hôtels qui est de
visitable de visites a peur en visite à
paris en fait et là ils sont déjà très
bien organisés ils ont les passes ils
ont les petites étiquettes alors en
suivant les pays n'ont pas tous
européens europe
ils ont passé seul et même système de 2
deux passes mais bon après on a on a vu
des passes je suis plus de quel pays ce
matin où il n'avait pas l'application on
devait accepter quoi voilà aujourd'hui
vous en tant que restaurateur qu'est ce
que ça vous procure finalement de devoir
demander à vos clients en passan iter ou
du moins le sésame aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on doit présenter pour prendre un
café
écoutez c'est pas évident c'est vrai que
nous en tant que restaurateurs on n'aime
pas faire ce genre de démarche mais
maintenant on a compris que le coc vide
il fallait le gérer comme ce à quoi il
faut il faut vraiment prendre conscience
que d'appréhender pour la suite
bien sûr qu'on appréhende toujours un
peu pour la suite on est toujours un peu
un peu
voilà on peut embêter on a surtout peur
d'un confinement clairement nous notre
métier il se fait qu'à travers le
service de l'opinion quoi l'on confond
faire tout pour éviter un conte un
confinement
donc là on est bien ou bien content
malgré tout de prendre les passes pour
pouvoir maintenir une activité quoi il
faut comprendre que dès l'instant où
nous nous sommes fermés on perd une
dynamique incroyable quoi nos salariés
ces partis veulent plus faire ce métier
on a beaucoup de mal à recruter
on arrive pas on n'arrive pas
instaurer un climat de confiance avec
nos salariés quoi puis nous on
fonctionne beaucoup en heures
supplémentaires ont fait que les
salariés de travail aussi parce qu'ils
ont des pourboires
donc ça c'est un ensemble qui se perd
dès l'instant où on est fermée quoi moi
j'ai eu énormément de mal à rouvrir et a
et aa seront motivés quoi même nous
autant patron avait du mal à se motiver
leur imaginer nos salariés encore moins
quoi clairement on montre un peu
l'exemple et là on avait du mal à le
montrer parce qu'on était on n'était pas
du tout dans le rythme à la réouverture
est là on ne savait pas trop s'en est
refermé rouvrir et ça c'est vraiment
c'était vraiment trop indécis et du coup
on avait du mal à motiver nos équipes
voilà donc ça prend du temps mais vous
n'avez pas trop le choix finalement et
vous allez le faire
nous on préfère vous préfère clairement
contrôler les parce que peut-être fermer
quoi merci ben écoute un merci
infiniment pour votre témoignage et je
vous souhaite beaucoup de monde en tout
cas aujourd'hui pour la reprise
merci beaucoup vous l'avez compris
beaucoup d'inquiétude un prêt
d'appréhension mais finalement ils n'ont
pas tous le choix et vont le faire et on
a pu parler également à quelques clients
qui sont plutôt satisfaits et qui estime
que c'est la règle et qu'il faut la
suivre et c'est peut-être la seule
manière de sortir de cette crise voilà
et pour ceux les restaurateurs qui ne
contrôleraient pas les passait bien il
risque une amende de 1500 euros
mona hamou dès lors en direct de saint
michel donc merci pour cette précision
merci également à olivier molinari qui
vous accompagnent derrière la caméra